[Music]
ethanol this molecule made of little
more than a few carbon atoms is
responsible for drunkenness often simply
referred to as alcohol ethanol is the
active ingredient in alcoholic beverages
its simplicity helps it sneak across
membranes and nestle into many different
notes producing a wide range of effects
compared to other clunkier molecules so
how exactly does it cause drunkenness
and why does it have dramatically
different effects on different people to
answer these questions will need to
follow alcohol on its journey through
the body
alcohol lands in the stomach and is
absorbed into the blood through the
digestive tract especially the small
intestine the contents of the stomach
impact our calls ability to get into the
blood because after eating the pyloric
sphincter which separates the stomach
from the small intestine closes so the
level of alcohol that reaches the blood
after a big meal might only be a quarter
that from the same drink on an empty
stomach from the blood alcohol goes to
the organs especially those that get the
most blood flow the liver and the brain
it hits the liver first and enzymes in
the liver break down the alcohol
molecule in two steps first an enzyme
called ADH turns alcohol into
acetaldehyde which is toxic then an
enzyme called ALDH converts the toxic
acetaldehyde to non-toxic acetate as the
blood circulates the liver eliminates
alcohol continuously but this first path
of elimination determines how much
alcohol reaches the brain and other
organs brain sensitivity is responsible
for the emotional cognitive and
behavioral effects of alcohol otherwise
known as drunkenness alcohol turns up
the brains primary break the
neurotransmitter gaba and turns down its
primary gas the neurotransmitter
glutamate
this makes neurons much less
communicative and users feel relaxed at
moderate doses fall asleep at higher
doses and can impede the brain activity
necessary for survival at
set doses alcohol also stimulates a
small group of neurons that extends from
the midbrain to the nucleus accumbens a
region important for motivation like all
addictive drugs it prompts a squirt of
dopamine in the nucleus accumbens which
gives users a surge of pleasure alcohol
also causes some neurons to synthesize
and release endorphins endorphins help
us to calm down in a response to stress
or danger elevated levels of endorphins
contribute to the euphoria and
relaxation associated with alcohol
consumption finally as the livers
breakdown of alcohol outpaces the
brain's absorption drunkenness fades
away individual differences at any point
in this journey can cause people to act
more or less drunk for example a man and
a woman who weigh the same and drink the
same amount during an identical meal
will still have different blood alcohol
concentrations or BAC s this is because
women tend to have less blood women
generally have a higher percentage of
fat which requires a less blood than
muscle a smaller blood volume carrying
the same amount of alcohol means the
concentration will be higher for women
genetic differences in the livers
alcohol processing enzymes also
influence BAC and regular drinking can
increase production of these enzymes
contributing to tolerance on the other
hand those who drink excessively for a
long time may develop liver damage which
has the opposite effect meanwhile
genetic differences in dopamine Garber
and endorphin transmission may
contribute to risk for developing an
alcohol use disorder those with
naturally low endorphin or dopamine
levels may self-medicate through
drinking some people have a higher risk
for excessive drinking due to a
sensitive endorphin response that
increases the pleasurable effects of
alcohol others have a variation in gaba
transmission that makes them especially
sensitive to the sedative effects of
alcohol which decreases their risk of
developing disordered drinking meanwhile
the brain adapts to chronic alcohol
consumption by reducing gaba dopamine
and endorphins mission an enhancing
glutamate activity this means
kilo drinkers tend to be anxious have
trouble sleeping and experience less
pleasure these structural and functional
changes can lead to disordered use when
drinking feels normal but not drinking
is uncomfortable establishing a vicious
cycle so both genetics and previous
experience impact how a person
experiences alcohol which means that
some people are more prone to certain
patterns of drinking than others and a
history of consumption leads to neural
and behavioral changes similar to
alcohol how someone experiences
marijuana depends on a number of factors
including for example genetics find out
more about the effects and risks of
marijuana use with this video
[Music]